hello youtubers you're in the right
place
and at the right time to catch our next
episode of star talk
a cosmic queries edition
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and we have a
cosmic queries edition but now it's kind
of they're
questions that kind of land in their own
category
and so what do you do when you put
questions together that belong
each in their own category you get a
kind of a grab bag a kind of a
cosmic curiosities all mixed together
and i got one guy who's who's a cosmic
curiosity himself paul mercurio paul how
are you look thanks for being on
don't talk i've been on your show yeah
paul mercurial show multiple times yeah
you were
great oh thank you yeah you say that to
all you no no no no
you you're actually i didn't think you
knew much about science but i was
surprised
you actually killed it no i love being
on your show because you're curious and
you're
you know your fans are curious and and i
like being
amid curious people because then i can
fulfill my prime directive as an
educator
i i told my wife that if i had you as a
science teacher
i'd probably be doing something in
science really because i do think the
message
is the medium in some level and the
person communicating and i had this guy
this big hulking bitter guy was in it 30
years better teachers bitter tea would
smoke like all right we're going to make
a battery today and they're like okay
what an exciting thing i remember eighth
grade i couldn't i'm
like this is the worst i gotta see in
chemistry but anyway
the way you and i know you come on with
stephen colbert a lot and i work on the
show he just loves
right you're the warm-up guy yeah but he
he brightens up when you come on
like in rehearsal who we have in there
oh god that's great i don't have to do
anything
i'll just ask one question he'll talk
for two seconds so you have a big fan
over there yeah no that's
excellent excellent so you collected all
the questions these are questions from
the uh gathered from the internet right
along with they're not specifically
solicited because they're leftovers
really oh they're like the leftovers i'm
a leftover guy this
is about right what did you want to call
this the cosmic cosmic catch-all
catch-all yeah the cosmic catch basin
how about paul's pathetic leftovers okay
paul's pathos right they all have mold
on them and everything
no um no these the people they should be
rewarded
for asking questions that fit in no
category yeah and they're very good
aren't enough people like that out there
yeah who who
walk at a pace that no one sees or
understands
that's a good way of putting it no no
there's a quote from nietzsche this is
one of my favorite quotes ever
those who were dancing were deemed
insane
by those who could not hear the music
whoa that's heavy
yeah i think we should end the show
there i don't think you're gonna
anything's gonna stop there
think about if you're looking through a
glass wall yeah and you don't hear the
music what are people and they're
that's so true they're just jumping up
and down waving their appendages
all these people are having seizures and
if there's no
if you don't know they're playing music
and you can't hear the music yeah you
you think they're insane it's a it's
definitely a good point because so
therefore i respect people who think
differently
in fact one could define genius that way
it's a genius is one who sees what
everyone else sees
but thinks what no one else has thought
were you always like this as a child and
i'm not going to make a joke no no no no
because like you're you're one of the
most
psychoanalyzing no no no i'm just
curious tell me about your parents
tell me yeah that's what this sounds
what what okay google
i i know i'm curious because of how
you're so well-versed not just in
astrophysics and science but
in pretty much everything and i'm just
curious
there's stuff i'm plenty of stuff i'm
not versed in i just don't talk about it
so she's a huge gaping hole but if i
don't talk about it you don't know how
unversed i am that's good pr
yeah no i just anyway no you know what
it is
you know what it is and i mean that as a
compliment i'm not trying to be funny
yeah it's hard to know if you're a
compliment
no i'm sure carol did i just compliment
him he's
he's asking his wife in the peanut
gallery yeah was that a compliment
of the spectrum of comments that come
out of your husband's mouth that counts
as a compliment
okay i hate to be in your home
oh god all right now we got three
segments of this we got more
okay let's get some first questions
going okay all right uh we're starting
with our patreon folks patreon folks got
it got it
gotta gotta prioritize thank you gotta
love the priority patreons this is john
callahan
is the name big bang a misnomer from
what i recall we don't actually have any
evidence the big bang started with an
explosion
like a supernova or a black hole merger
yeah so first of all
the big bang was a name given to this
idea
that the universe started in this one
primordial
explosion it was given pejoratively
to this idea by proponents of what at
the time was known as the steady state
theory hypothesis of the universe one
way the universe always was and always
will be
even though it's expanding it's always
been expanding
and matter is spontaneously created in
the vacuum
to fill in for where space is getting
thinner so that you'd always see a
universe that looked about the same
this is called the steady state
hypothesis you could
get that out of einstein's equations of
gravity that was allowed
but another solution was one where we're
either collapsing or where we're
expanding all three solutions were
allowed
the one with the big bang itself uh
there was eq it was an equal competitor
to the steady state theory
for decades until we finally got some
evidence
to support the big bang and that was the
famous micro cosmic microwave background
this is a
leftover signal signature from
an explosion that started in one hot
primeval fireball
13.8 billion years ago thank you sir
okay
you don't need me for this no that was
the only thing i remember
with the 13.85 you're showing off now no
i was showing off
okay right so so it was it was given as
a
as as a funny pejorative name but it's
stuck and
and if it fits it fits now it's not
clear how much noise it would have made
because just the expansion of space
itself is not you know that's not
associated with noise
in space is vacuum anyway and noise
doesn't propagate
so if you don't want to call it the big
bang
because it was probably made no noise
[Laughter]
you think you'd fix that by now no you
call it
uh how about the main event
let's get ready to blow up yeah i think
the the big event but
you know yeah the main event well you've
talked about laws and theories and what
used to be called remember that
that's a that's a subtle point in the
old days
we come up with an understanding of the
universe a new law has been discovered
that's a very exciting time in science
when that happens and then you learn
later on
that with better instruments and more
tools
and deeper thinkers that what you came
up with as a law
was a smaller subset of a larger
understanding
so you don't really you shouldn't call
it a law right it's it's a
but it works right so we just use the
word theory for everything that works
now
right and if you if you just have an
idea that hasn't been tested we call
hypothesis paul's hypothesis right well
there's a lot of those about paul's bs
hypothesis
but there's something right exactly
um there's something you said in this
context you said
as a quote yours what happened in the
20th century is that we came to learn
that whatever we determined to be true
about the universe
may only be a subtext of a larger truth
yeah that's right not that would later
shown to be wrong
right so it's not like science goes from
one truth to another truth
discarding previous truths not the
physical sciences at least
um not since the 1600s have we been in
that situation
before the 1600s that's about when we
uh the methods and tools and practices
of what we now call modern science
were forged galileo francis bacon
folks said you know if you have an idea
about how the world works you should
test it
i don't care how it looks yeah i don't
care what your senses tell you
come up with an experiment that goes a
little beyond your senses or extends
your senses
galileo had a telescope uh liu and oak
had a microscope
you start seeing directions that were
previously
inaccessible to your sensory system
right your eyes
your your sense of touch taste smell and
so
the universe comes to you now
outside of your the experience of your
senses right
and the experiment then becomes the
measure of what is true
not whether it makes sense and one of my
recent books the the the front
piece the i mean the the epigraph
epigram
a grammar epigraph i always forget what
they're called uh if you don't know i'm
not
it's i just said i just lead i just i
just
baptize people into this by saying the
universe
is under no obligation to make sense to
you yeah
but it's it's we're always in a state of
subtext then in some way
possibly yeah there's some things we
might know completely right
but uh let it be open enough to say this
is a subset of a larger
understanding newton's laws of motion
and gravity worked
did he experience anything faster than a
running horse well that's for the
gravity of the earth right
and so it worked right in fact it got us
to the moon and back right
but then we have particle accelerators
and we can move close to the speed of
light
and we say you know newton's laws are
those weird things your knowledge is
limited by what you can do at that time
in the 20 and the
correct and and einstein came up with
his laws
his theories of of of motion and gravity
and we learned that it's a deeper
understanding of reality that still has
limits right
his you know where einstein's theories
leave what leave us high and dry
at the singularity of the black hole and
at the singularity of the big bang
itself
it's like dividing by zero you remember
you're not supposed to do that in math
class
right right okay so there's a there's a
poster that said probably a t-shirt by
now
that said a black hole the center of a
black hole that's where god is dividing
by zero
right okay so i thought that was cute so
so singularities are now the
frontier of string theorists and others
who are trying to take it to the next
level got it
just one other thing on this hawking
said the boundary condition of the
universe
is that it has no boundary is that sort
of what you're
that's a way to think about it i think
that's a
it's it's a it's an organizational
thought right for you
okay you can say what is here you go
ready
uh holding flat earthers aside so i
assume you agree that earth is spherical
it depends okay so
so if i say to you start walking and
call me when you get to the edge of the
earth
you'll say i'm not going to do that
because earth has no edge
meanwhile you can walk forever and never
get to an edge
right so what are the boundary
conditions of the earth
is there an edge no right there's no
edge right
so so so you can have things that have
no boundaries
they're real the surface of the earth is
wonderful so if you can have that on
earth
uh
and imagine an entire universe that has
no edge right and no boundary
you can have no boundary in time we live
forever as a universe there's no
boundary at the other end of time i
gotta tell you i love you your job's
annoying because there's never an answer
at the end of it no we got to no no
no i take you to places where we don't
have answers because that's where things
are coolest
but there's plenty of stuff we have
answers to the age of the earth where
humans came from i got this uh okay you
know what i like about astrophysics it's
like
the names you come up with other people
got the coolest names well wait a minute
other science like zoology whatever it's
like latin phrases you have like
quark spooky action in big bang who's
is this beavis and butthead yes no we
call it like we see him
okay we we
okay the beginning of space time energy
and the universe big bang
we're into one-syllable communication
for people like me to get it okay
there's a region of space where uh you
fall in you don't come out light doesn't
come out
black hole okay there's a crater in
arizona made by a meteor
we call it meteor crater okay all the
other sciences
come up with these huge latin greek
derived
fre words cretaceous paleolithic paleo
the deoxyribone apocalypse
i would say big tooth animal that's what
we call it
maybe make that noise make it on a
monopoetic so
i think it's why so much of our
vocabulary has been
absorbed and adopted into the marketing
of products
yeah pulsar watches i don't they still
make them but that was a watch and a
quasar
brand um tv uh tvs and microwave ovens
in the old days
but today uh i think it's the
second the third highest category
of where you draw names from to name
cars
astrophysics yes yes yes so no or
science
science leaning astro uh so let's start
off okay
all right all right aren't you supposed
to be asking me questions that yeah
okay all right all right you want me to
go to it i count you as a questioner
you're too okay so fine okay
this counts as paul's question no no i
can go to the first question
i'm sorry fine wait fine do you want me
to ask the next question no we're doing
paul's question and make everyone pissed
off at you oh i'm sorry i'm done i'm
done
that's fine i'm done that's fine i'm
done so the number one in car names i
think are
names that don't mean anything like um
like the
s-class for mercedes just letters and
digits and numbers right okay the the
the m class
and with a number okay then you have
locations
like yukon or denali
tell your eyes oh yeah these are places
that okay i think third is like science
name science astrophysics name
and i made a whole list of them is that
right yes i got a hold let me read i got
it right here in my pocket
okay okay give me a second pull this up
i swear to god i'm happy to go to the
next question
no the audience will be pissed off at
you that's fine
they'll be pissed off at you not me okay
so
here we go uh cosmic car names you ready
yeah yeah here we go okay ready
uh okay uh between 1973 and 1975
yeah um what had just finished what have
we just finished doing just before that
uh getting rid of nixon that that's true
we just
we just finished going to the moon yes
the car called the apollo oh
yes i forgot about that yeah we forgot
you that old it was a buick
uh of course general motors okay and
then i got
um 2008 to 2009 the saturn
car company whoa there okay they had a
car called the astra
which is which is basically star in
latin
okay i got that but this can go on and
on and on
uh you tell me when to shut up uh 2005
to current
the chevy equinox i'm taking it oh
equinox you didn't know that these okay
no keep going here we go
another one uh saturn going back to
saturn which the car can be does not
exist anymore
but saturn from 2003 to 2007 had the ion
i'm taking it the ion it's chemistry but
i we
the enti the sun is a ball of ionized
gas called plasma oh so
all stars are all right i'll give you
it's a cousin really it's not but
excuse me most of the universe is
ionized i'm taking it
okay i'm not giving that to you okay the
famous one here
1962-1979 and again 1985 to 198
the chevy nova oh
that was the car we made out in oh wait
what's
yep for those only listening you should
say who you were making out with oh
my wife carol who was in the peanut
gallery of the studio yeah we went to
high school together
and you may not have no it's not all
that large we had a chevy nova
okay and we would uh go get a bench
front seat so yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't a [ __ ] scene yeah you
couldn't move the steering wheel he's
got the biggest smile
i don't think people know that a nova
was a star that had just blown up i
think chevy had they known that they
might have found it
well it's also me it's no go no going in
spanish in spanish i've got another
20 cards in this list i just want to say
by the way for those
listening it's proof he has it on his
phone and he has so many that he's
he must have did about 70 swipes he just
kept going and going and going
all right plus um ask me what gum i chew
trident nope eclipse thank you there you
go or orbit
orbit i prefer the the the harder gum
rather than the softer
right so you're really committed to your
crap so and there's moon glow
bath beads you've got celestial
seasonings tea you've got
milky way candy bar mars candy bar even
that's the name of the family
they named it mars and it's red okay the
packaging is red i'm taking it
that's the only time we have for today
everybody have one we got 30 seconds
left
what's the next question the next
question is from another patreon uh
paul blew the entire first segment one
gazette asks will space tourism require
some fundamentally new technology to
make it affordable for everyday people
this is patrick foles
washington and we will get to that
question in the next segment when star
talk returns
you may not know this but we actually
have a pretty small
team at star talk we don't have a
full-time graphic designer or video
editor so we use story blocks for many
of our visuals
the story blocks unlimited plan gives
you all the 4k studio
quality video you could want do you need
space exploration footage
they got it do you need video of bananas
they have it and yes you guessed it they
have puppies
lots and lots of puppies check out the
link in the description to learn more
about storyblocks video
that's storyblocks.com star talk
oh puppies star talk
we're back the cosmic queries edition
where it's really a grab bag
before mercurial my co-host today thanks
for being on fall absolutely from the
paul mercurial show
yeah podcast and itunes i've been on it
several times and it's always fun being
on there with you thank you um thanks
for
coming thanks for having me i've been a
big fan of the show it was really like
an honor to be asked to do this and and
you collected
not out of one category you just you got
the drags
of everybody yeah but i think it's cool
because it's like it's a mixed bag it's
fun you know it's not just one topic you
know
you've got dark matter yeah i think some
of them are the best questions yeah
right they don't they don't
there's several dark marks in a beat of
a different drummer yeah
so what what we have do you call this
paul's what uh cosmic
uh cosmic catch-all catch-all yeah there
you go okay all right so reread that
question before we
exited that last segment this is a
patreon uh person in one hive gazette
patrick foles in uh mill creek wisco uh
washington asphalt space tourism
requires some fundamentally new
technology to make it affordable
for everyday people yeah so that's a
really good question what's interesting
about
access to space is if you remember your
econ 101 we think the demand
is completely elastic
okay and an elastic demand would be if
you drop the price more people will do
it if you raise the price fewer people
will do it but there's
always a demand at a price okay that's
one of the measures
of whether something is elastic if it's
inelastic it doesn't matter what price
you charge
everyone has to buy it and you can drive
some people bankrupt or whatever
but elastic is like most products you
want them to be elastic it's a healthy
economy
okay tourist seats have already been
sold on the space station by the
russians because the
americans wouldn't do it and how much
were they with their 20 million dollars
why wouldn't we do it
because it's not our that's not how we
roll okay there's america
not for for our greatest frontier no so
for example we
have the right stuff if you could just
buy the right stuff it ain't the right
stuff yeah
so our image of going into space okay
had some of that yeah you want to write
stuff you don't want to sell it right
yeah yeah yeah exactly i think that was
that no one would say that but i think
that was part of it but don't you think
it's inevitable there no wait i'm
getting it i'm getting there
exactly no no don't apologize for
interrupting me this is new york
if you interrupt me that's my only
evidence that you're paying attention to
me
okay i'm sorry who are you again
so so you can drop the price so if you
made it 10 million
uh there might be 10 people who will go
up if you have a billion dollars
10 million is lunch money right a lot of
billionaires today
make it 1 million then you have all the
like 100 millionaires okay so there
as you go down the economic ladder the
number of people who i think would be
interested in this
would continue to grow plus i bet i
don't know your budget
i don't know what you do on holiday i'm
not going to ask but i bet
you would save two years
of holiday expenses to go on one space
trip
and you stay home and watch tv and all
the other holidays when you might have
gone to aruba
or whatever does my wife have to come
yes she's in the room now the answer is
can i go on a craft called nova
so i so i think there's a price that you
can
you just keep doing this then if there's
a price below which it can't go
make a lottery oh interesting yes
yes so let's say you can't get it below
a million dollars right
so you sell a million lottery tickets
for a dollar you could do that every
single time
how low every single seat will go for a
dollar
well you can sell for a dollar and you
get the one person and that's the
million the 10 million dollars it pays
for that one person see you could
you could do that every time how long do
you think this the price
could go realistically it's tough it's
it's getting into space yeah it really
is
yeah uh i don't i don't know it's tough
do you trust the technology on the
private side to get it right and do it
right
do you mean to not kill you yes no
people will die
for that's what happened with the first
airplanes people die right now people
you're a bad commercial for this no
that's just how this works
go to space die no no go to space first
die
okay people say that's true people said
uh if elon musk you know has a
spacecraft to mars would you take his
the first spaceship i said no
i wait till after he sends his mother
and brings her back right
if he can do that then i'm going on the
trip i'm bringing the thing yeah
get a good netflix account and occupy
the nine months to get there
listen i believe in science if you if
you can make disney in disney world
affordable then i know we got something
yeah so i think
i think you'd have to do lottery if the
ticket doesn't come down to the
thousand dollar vacation that we would
all take
paying for an airplane and rental car at
a hotel
to go to a beach you're dropping
anywhere between one and five thousand
dollars for a family
um that you might have saved up to do
and
i don't see it coming that getting that
cheap i don't see that happening
to me it's come faster than i thought it
would i mean there was talk of it seemed
like it just talked about a few years
ago and suddenly like we're
close to making this happen yeah and so
as a thing
we'll watch the rich people do it first
by the way rich people were the first to
fly in airplanes
just that's this is you know that's a
good point the first
president to do it that was headline
news president flies on an airplane okay
quick prediction we'll move on how many
carry-ons am i allowed
i think um you
right now yeah access to orbit costs ten
thousand dollars a pound
no matter what it is whoa yes so i can't
do that fake i have an emotional problem
can i bring my dog
well then you pay ten thousand dollars a
pound for your dog so a lot of
chihuahuas are on this trip
forget
the bloodhound and the great danes are
you having a great day
on a weight loss program you want to go
to space run no
it happened no so ten thousand dollars a
pound elon musk is trying to get that
down
but i don't think he's gonna get it to a
thousand dollars a pound and what do you
weigh 150 pounds
yeah so there'll be 150 000 way less
than a million
but yeah and and i bet
if you weighed 160 but you could drop to
150
you'd do that to save the 10 000
absolutely go into space
so i'd go on naked just to save the
weight on clothes
um all right so you're talking about
carry-ons there may be some
some seriously important carry-on can i
take my bowling mall on
that's going to cost you 15 000 right no
all right we're going to go on to uh
another bowling would be hard in space
by the way just wait
if we're going there leave your bowling
ball at home if you get a strike in
space and you don't hear it did it
happen
uh if you got a striking space and you
didn't hear it you'd be bowling in a
vacuum
with a spacesuit on and that would be
weird we would we would make a place
where there's air
and you could breathe okay we would do
that for you and your bowling ball
all right okay and one other thing real
quick i saw you talking about something
and you talked about the movie gravity
you made the point that sandra bullock's
bangs the bags always pointed down
hilarious
bangs knew where gravity was
everything's floating around everything
floating around the bangs didn't budge
that that angered me first irrationally
and whoever cut it
like immediately went to her face and
just she looked great you're right they
were down they were perfect they were
straight everything around here
no i now was i was i wrong to to go
there
no you were totally well here's my thing
here's my let me just let me just
defend myself for the moment if you look
at any picture of somebody in space
who has long hair the first thing you
notice
is that the hair is everywhere that's
the first thing that's a good point
the women who go up with all their long
hair and they don't tie it in the thing
sticking straight up is that why kelly
the bald guy he's bullied
he doesn't want us he wants to keep you
guessing if he's in space or if he's on
a sound stage
mark kelly might be one of the other
twins yeah i think it might be scott i
don't know
scott scott which one did we interview
on star talk we had
um one one of those two twins uh we had
the better looking one apparently that's
as he introduced himself
scott kelly i think it was uh he yeah
maybe he had long dreadlocks
let me mess with them um all right so
we're going to go on to uh another
patreon uh
supporter uh one hive gazette this is uh
this is this is the same a gentleman
this is uh
getting two questions in there all right
dark matter seems to be a placeholder
for unexplained gravitational forces in
the universe
is it possible that our understanding of
gravity is incomplete
could gravity work differently on
galactic scales
not likely it's an excellent question
first
it's not so much a placeholder it is a
placeholder
but it's not we measure this thing out
there and we don't
that has gravity associated with it and
we don't know what it is
come up with a name call it something
call it fred i don't care what you call
it it's a thing
right it's got gravity we measure its
gravity it interacts with matter
by gravity so we happen to call it dark
matter and everyone's thinking oh is it
matter is it
it's really dark gravity oh
dark matter implies you know you know
it's matter
we would label it correctly just like
the big bang we'd have to call it the
big event
right the silent scientific the main
event
uh if it didn't make any sound uh
we dark gravity is the accurate thing we
should be calling it and we don't know
what it is
but we can calculate it with it and you
put it in the equations and it works
there's a term here's the extra graph
the extra stuff
dark the dark matter is it 85
or something like that yeah uh so 85
of all gravity in the universe is of
unknown origin
gravity that we measured so yeah it
could be that we need a deeper
understanding of gravity on larger
scales
but we have examples of colliding
galaxies
and you can run the numbers on it
and regular gravity accounts for that
and then you throw in dark matter to
account for some other things that are
going on
so i don't i i
we think it's not that right yeah how
slow by the way there is there is a
there's a subcottage industry of people
who think we just have to modify gravity
modify newtonian gravity and they
abbreviated that m-o-n-d
modified newtonian and they called mond
the mond people you type mond in
wiki you'll get all this description of
taking newton's gravity and
adding a term to it for a large scale
thing and that you can fit a few things
but there's some things you can't fit
right with it so we think it's we think
it's something else that we simply don't
know what it is
well you said you you this is something
you said you don't know if it's made of
matter it's a misnomer to send people
in thought directions that's not the
right path i don't say it's not the
right path
it's it's it's you don't want to mislead
you don't want to prejudge what it could
be
because then people use the word and
then they get caught up in the word
and then the word becomes the thing
rather than the idea are you a wimp a
wimp
proponent a weakly interacting massive
particles yeah
yeah sure the possibility of what role
they could play in the universe
sure i mean in the universe
astrophysicists we're open to anything
it's there we are so ignorant of so much
stuff
we just take any you got an idea bring
it on and and give us ways we might test
it and we'll test it
is there a process of elimination is
there like are you all oh
you're crossing things off the list you
want to come up with a hypothesis that
has enough detail in your predictions
that we can rule it out if we make the
experiment if you just say oh it could
be just something that's
there when you don't look at it but then
it's there it's further
then give me a prediction if you have a
prediction you're not it's not useful
okay so their hypotheses that are put on
the table
the the more fuzzy wuzzy they are the
less useful they are and you just
discard them
it's the ones that say if this idea is
correct you should find this
if you look in that direction and then
we do it we find it hey
you're on to something give me another
prediction up that failed
okay should you modify your hypothesis
or and by the way if your predictions
keep coming right
right we elevate your hypothesis to a
theory oh
that's how you get to theory of gravity
you get quantum theory you get
relativity theory you get
evolutionary theory these are ideas that
started out as an hypothesis
elevated to a working understanding of
how the universe works
that has predictive value is it is it
possible that
our understanding of gravity is so vague
that
my bathroom scale could be off so that
i'm actually lighter than i that's the
part of gravity we understand precisely
yeah i'm just saying all right okay
we're going to move on
another by the way people don't talk
about this because of the centrifugal
force
of the rotating earth you weigh less on
the equator than you do on the nor on
the pole
because the earth is trying to spin you
off and so you actually weigh a little
less at the equator
you weigh less here than you do in
canada really yeah
yeah but not only that earth is slightly
wider at the
equator than it is at the pole so you're
farther away from the center of the
earth
so you weigh less for that reason as
well you also weigh less because
you are immersed in a fluid called
air there's a buoyancy
that you have in air air is a fluid if
it takes the shape of its container it's
a fluid
you can have liquids and gases or fluids
and so fluid dynamics which is an entire
branch
of physics and engineering involves the
movement of
things that would that are would take so
the movement of
of water around bridge embankments the
movement of air over
the the wings of planes it's all fluid
dynamics
so so so why did i talk about that where
where was i going with this
um because i asked you if the laws of
gravity are so vague that
my scale could be yeah yeah no sorry
that's oh yeah you started you just
gave your scale so i'm saying so here's
here's how to go on the equator where
you get the centrifugal forces
right you weigh a little less than you
would then santa claus would weigh less
on the equator than on the north pole
okay okay and you also weigh less on the
equator because earth is slightly wider
at the equator
than it is pole to pole right and you'd
also weigh
less if you went to a mountaintop
because you're farther away from earth
center than if you went down
in a in a mine for example carol we're
moving to an equator i want to be able
to eat moving to a
mountain on an equipment waiter now
where you go now you're talking pizza
every day get your six ounces
whatever when we come back with paul
mercurio
on star talk we're gonna do more cosmic
queries from the dustbin
when we return okay i was so distracted
by puppies in the last commercial break
that i also started looking up videos of
kittens on storyblocks video
if you were working on a project and
need stock footage
you'll want to use storyblocks video and
their giant library because you get
unlimited downloads try stuff out if it
doesn't work
try some more create like a pro with the
newest
highest quality content sourced from a
select group of artists
that storyblocks partners with check out
the link
in the description to learn more about
storyblocks video
that's storyblocks.com star talk
star talk we're back paul mercurio on
loan from the paul mercurio show did
did you allow yourself to be loaned out
to us okay you have to check the
authorities on that one
i bought myself a car service and
everything uh yes i got permission to be
out just for the day just for the day
they let you out i said please it's
nearly like all right and you brought
your wife she's in the in the studio
with us here
welcome tell me your name again carol
welcome to star talk
so you got some more questions for me we
uh we're going
we're sticking with dark matter um this
is kale honeyset
instagram do you think that once doctor
dark matter is discovered and understood
would it actually help in space travel
so i'm gonna answer a bigger question
than that
almost by the way we've already
discovered dark matter we just don't
know what it is
okay so let me what she means there is
once we know what dark matter is made of
okay we've already discovered it it's
there can we then use it okay by the way
but
there's a long history of discovering
things that we don't know what it is
okay that's
this is not a first time you discover
something the kardashians
okay what is this why am i watching this
exactly how did this come about
the magic
matter force is operating on our culture
that's the 85 percent
85 so once we find out what is i can say
more broadly that practically
every scientific discovery there ever
was
when you have enough clever engineers
and other folks in the pipeline
we find a way to apply it to our
everyday lives
in this case maybe space travel maybe we
can exploit its existence
as we move through space maybe we can
isolate a dark matter
particle here on earth and use it for
you know walking through walls dark
matter doesn't interact
with ordinary matter in ordinary ways in
fact it it moves through it as though
it's not there at all
so how do we know that if we don't know
what it is you can
log the behavior of things effects
exactly
okay so you say here's the region of
space we don't see any matter no light
is coming out except
stuff is getting attracted to it must be
the stuff that gets
moves through it unimpeded with its
speed
so i'm attracted to it yet it's not
slowing me down i'm not
plowing into anything right so dark
matter and
quote regular matter can move through
each other with no effect at all
so maybe that's how you make ghosts
maybe this is these are the spirits of
all the dead people
you've been up into the do you believe
in any of this no
next question but
okay there's been about 100 billion
people ever born on earth maybe a little
less like 80 billion
so and we got about 7 billion here now
so let's
80 billion minus seven uh that would get
you down to so that's
73 billion uh ghosts out there
so first that's a lot of ghosts people
said do you believe in ghosts no because
there'd be so many of them
there'd be ten times as many ghosts as
there are people it's like it's so
annoying
it's like get out of here i'm busy
everywhere you turn there's a ghost
there's a ghost
enough with the ghosts already great
caesar's ghosts
so where where was i before we were
talking about
70 million there's 73 million ghosts so
here's the thing
the total number of humans ever born
doesn't amount to that much mass
there's way more mass in the universe in
dark matter than ever
could be equaled by the ghosts of dead
people
so you can't appeal to the ghost of dead
people or lost socks
in the in the in the in the washing
machine
space-time continuum jerry seinfeld
thing where the sock is up against the
dryer wall
trying to get out um next question all
right
uh by the way on this dark round i think
real quick the
the idea that you can't define it we
don't know what it is that's a good way
to scare kids like if you don't go to
bed dark matter's going to get you you'd
like freak them out
oh did you ever think about that no i
didn't all right so do you have kids
yes we do how old are we i'm not sure
i'm trying to get too close
um okay okay we're gonna we're gonna
move away from dark matter we've got a
few of those
uh this is from uh mike parker facebook
when something explodes in space as is
shown on numerous tv shows and movies
is there really a shock wave in a vacuum
so
good question okay so this person
clearly knows there's no sound
to move you only get a shock wave if
energy is moving through a medium okay
and so
example of a medium oh anything okay
yeah
anything okay that's how bombs work
a bomb works because it creates a shock
wave that moves through
air then walls then your flesh
ghosts okay i haven't seen experiments
on ghosts yet
there's 73 million of them you should
get on it no billion
billion wow i screwed that up
sorry go ahead so uh so it goes through
these mediums
um and so uh generally
in a supernova which is some of our best
shock waves in the universe
the star that was once there had shed a
lot of gas
into the vacuum of space and deep down
is where you get the explosion
and so the explosion happens sending a
shock wave rippling through
the gas that it had spread out into
space you see these beautiful photos of
these
terribly disturbed gaseous regions the
shock wave had blown through it by the
time it gets
out the other end of the of the
material then the shockwave can't
propagate
so what it does is it accelerates
particles at the end with that leftover
energy
you get very high moving fast moving
particles it's a fun thing
is this where newton's third law comes
into play newton's steroid always comes
in
oh just there but not with you yeah
these laws apply everywhere at all times
sometimes yes okay yeah
my ass put my butt is pushing down on
the scene and it pushes back
exactly so you have this energy moving
through and it needs to manifest and at
the edge of the
edge of the gas you get this
acceleration happens at the edge of the
sun as well
you get these accelerating particles at
the edge of the sun oh very cool
really yeah it's part of the solar wind
actually
does any of the stuff that happens on
star trek is any of that true because
i mean i i learned i learned klingon so
i hope it's not a waste of time
klingon you're in the club wow no i
didn't learn klingon i said no i'm going
to use my brain for other things
i knew enough back then that that's how
i should be using my brain
all right we're going to do it by the
way the the photon torpedoes
or the or the phasers the the ship
phasers yeah shoot forward yeah
if they're directing their energy to the
ship in front of them you should not see
them from the side
there's no energy coming out it's like
when the it's like when the speedometer
is on your windshield in a really fancy
car you can only see it straight on
uh oh this because it's in a well okay
that's because it doesn't let you see it
from the side because it's in a
it's in a cylindrical cavity oh well
the digital ones oh so what they do is
they have a like a
a polarized screen so only the driver
would see it you know but that's not why
this is the case
when you see when you see a laser
through the air it's because air is
reflect particles in the air
are reflecting the laser light to you on
the side
but if it's starship against klingon
ship
in the vacuum of space and you send a
light beam forward
you have no idea the light beam is there
you got it yeah you said that about
rudolph's red nose that it doesn't emit
light it reflects reflection
it would reflect light but let's we can
allow it to admit light why do you know
everything i've ever written or said
this is a little spooky i'm just
supposed to know stuff this is this is
i'm sorry it's bordering on what's the
word you have uh
uh um look we we're
at the five minute mark which means we
have to go into lightning round okay
here we go okay so that means i
i will answer every question and i will
with a with a sound bite
okay okay and then i will move because
we training for when i'm on the evening
news
because they only they only want sound
bites out of me anyway should be like a
game show this is for a car there we go
okay uh okay brian admiral
facebook hi neil can you please talk
about why scientists are so intent
on catching neutrinos on earth and what
they can tell us about the universe
thank you in advance excellent so every
nuclear
process that goes on in the center of
the sun and the center of every star
every every nuclear event
that happens has neutrinos associated
with it
so for every hydrogen atom that becomes
helium it becomes a helium atom there's
a neutrino emitted
and neutrinos are hard to block in fact
they exit the sun without any trouble at
all
and so neutrinos are the
s signposts of
intense nuclear activity wherever you
happen to be looking
and we think that there's a neutrino
blast from the early universe
when the universe was formed and we need
we want to create neutrino telescopes
that could see that
this would be for neuchinos what the
cosmic microwave background was
for the big bang and the rest of our
understanding of the big bang they're
going to take us even farther back in
time so neutrinos
they they're where the action is i'm
sorry that's not the correct answer
thank you for playing okay
uh we're going to miriam
i'm sorry if i'm butchering that that's
right nicest usually here messes up
every word
at present how accurately can we
intercept possible signals from
intelligent aliens excellent here's the
problem
uh let's say you assert that they're
going to communicate
in this frequency so now you build a
particular frequency now you build a
telescope
doesn't it matter on their cell plan
okay it's exactly international
is it 3g or forward so so now i'm going
to listen on that frequency but which
way am i going to point the telescope
i'm going to point it this way
suppose they're giving me a message on a
different frequency
why would i listen to that or how about
a different frequency from that suppose
they're not in that direction
suppose they're behind you are we
suppose they sent the message
ten minutes ago before you started
listening right you were in the shower
this is called the parameter space of
communication
and are they using your frequency at
your time from that direction
and if it all has to match up so you
need a detector
that can listen to all frequencies you
need to look in
all directions and you need to look at
for all of time and we don't have that
we're not there yeah we're not there are
we working toward that
it's hard okay it's hard plus suppose
they sent us a message
and it came during the roman empire and
no one
caught the message because they didn't
invent radio waves discover radio waves
yet and then nobody sends back a signal
they might conclude there's no sign of
intelligent life on earth yet you have
the entire roman coliseum
and statues and what we call
intelligence so
yeah just no
okay let's get some more in yes luke
these are these little answers are too
long i gotta get make them even shorter
luke the inventor instagram do you think
if people traveled closer to the edge of
the universe with a huge telescope
they would be able to see past it to the
other side and will they see a giant
fetus and then an old man in a white
bedroom what does that mean no i'm just
kidding
uh space odyssey uh yes uh if you travel
with a huge telescope edge
uh will you be able to see past it to
the other side and what would they see
we are bound by the horizon established
by the speed of light
and so if you could travel faster than
the speed of light
you could then get ahead of the signal
that came from your past
and then
right now we don't know how to go faster
than light we don't have wormholes or
anything
so you're stuck in your present or and
in your future but the moment you can
travel faster than light
you can get ahead of the light beam that
you created in your past
and be able to see your life unfold
before your eyes next
i don't know if i'd want to see that um
i don't know what you've been into
shava bello at emily lewis
instagram what obstacles do you think
space tourism will face
here's one no one talks about okay i
send you up in space you are weightless
how many of us have experience being
weightless none of us
by the way it's the experience you get
on an amusement park ride
except more so and so in space if you
throw up
all your vomit continues to float in the
air and doesn't go into a splatter
diagram
on the ground right okay you have a goat
you see you know
3 a.m you take the fun out of everything
you walk the streets outside of bars the
throat pattern is very clear
okay it's very they are different but
they're all said generally
they're all different but they have
there's a general recurring
geometric pattern okay there's always
some carrots in there in the middle
somewhere
all right that he ate seven years you
know that right so
so we trust gravity to gather the vomit
in one place
but in space when you're in zero g it's
everywhere so if you have all these
newbie tourists throwing up everywhere
it will smell it'll get in your hair
it's just beautiful you have to put them
in a centrifuge and get them all
like that thing and get them used that
gives you extra gravity when you're
incentive you see how i did the
astrophysics thing which
is that's the sound thing that you would
not hear in space right so
you really do ruin everything all right
give me one last one real quick
okay uh julian garcia okay we know where
the center of the galaxy is but does
anyone know where the center of the
universe is
ooh there is there is no center
of the universe the center is in fact
everywhere
you want the center of the universe go
back in time 3.8 billion years
ask my wife i tweeted that one i said um
there is no center of the universe so
you can't be it
okay that's great so
if you want to think of a center of the
universe you have to go back in time
when we were smaller
13.8 billion years ago when all the
universe was in the same place
at the same time think of that as the
center
but then we're all at the same place at
the same time so now as we expand
the center of the universe is everywhere
yeah and that place is
like a fraction no i'm just saying it is
now everywhere that center of the
universe is now the entire universe
because we were all in the same place at
the same time now that being said
just because a thing exists doesn't mean
it has to have a center
where is the center of earth's surface
tell me
uh the corner of 88th avenue
paul we gotta end it there
well paul from the paul mercurial show
yes thanks for having us
i'm glad thanks for coming to our show
no thank you for having me this is
really really
fun got the coolest gig in the world
warming up the audience for stephen
colbert yeah cbs
uh at sullivan theater yeah it's a
really cool theater yes and it's always
good to see you there the the several
times i've been on this yeah try to come
by and say hi and
they've been nice enough they've been on
the show a few bunch of times too it's
great yeah i've been steven and i go
back to the daily show together
so oh cool it's uh it's it's really
great to see how the shows like
come together yeah yeah exactly and he
found his his groove
yeah you know because he's not a
stand-up he's that's not his thing and
he really like
he got he got it he got it yeah and
you're always so great on the show
oh thank you colbert oh no this is a
high compliment and by the way like
you see them all oh yeah yeah you know
because you know
when a guest is like the staff hangs out
around the tv i don't i'm not a big fan
of this but
um no they do and like
you know you know you you work on it
sometimes people go to who's on the show
today like i don't know like
it's like a job right but like i just
you should know that like
oh neil's on and everybody's standing
around well thank you i try to say
something interesting about the universe
i'm glad sometimes absolutely all right
absolutely all right
we're done there i you've been listening
to possibly even watching star talk
and i your host will degrass tyson as
always bid you
to keep looking up okay before we go i
want to thank storyblocks for sponsoring
this episode of star talk
like i said storyblocks video gives you
more clips than you can
ever need with their unlimited plan just
like we do at star talk
you can use their content on youtube
instagram and anywhere you want to make
yourself look like a pro
it's such a pain in the butt to record
your own stock footage
like let's say you want to show an
underwater experience
now you got to get to the airport you
got to fly to the caribbean you gotta
get yourself a boat you gotta get the
hotel
you gotta of course stop the bar have a
few drinks okay then take some time on
the beach because you know you need to
relax before you get in that water
now you gotta get your scuba gear then
you gotta dive finally you get to shoot
a fish or what you could do
is just do what we did and use the
extensive library of video from
storyblocks
anything in the video member library is
yours to download as much as you want
including hd and 4k footage after
effects
templates motion backgrounds and more
when you sign up for the unlimited video
plan check out the link in the
description to learn more about
storyblocks video
that's storyblocks.comtalk
i'll see you in the caribbean